[Music]
here's some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently check this one out 11 guys who
are no longer douchebags since they took
off their fedoras there's this one right
here 15 scary charts that don't make any
sentence I can't figure that one out at
all look this one 13 escalators that may
or may not be working here's one to
unclogged Guy Fieri arteries that
there's only two he's running out of
time and look at this one
eight kittens wearing top hats kitten is
so small that the top hat obscures the
kitten
we're doing all right now check out this
187 unremarkable Fort Worth area
buildings they're really scraping the
bottom of the bag yeah look at this one
12 dead guys in coffins who are going
commando he's happy I'm happy 21
perfectly sane people wearing foil hats
check out this one 16 chefs that were
almost might is this list right here for
Woody Allen films you can still watch
without getting the cream 23 Ruby
Tuesday managers whose wives are
secretly cheating on them that's too bad
oh whatever what doesn't know won't hurt
him 24 Girl Scouts who didn't turn in
all the cookie money
she looks good
yeah it's got a nice purse yeah 37 owls
who still don't think women should be
allowed to vote look at that out I just
don't like it
and finally seven futons that can keep a
secret
[Applause]
you